Sheila isn't going to make it harder it
is well so preet the US attorney in
Manhattan had a conference call earlier
today and he is very unhappy with this
and he said this could basically create
a roadmap for unscrupulous traders and
so what it means is that prosecutors
have to show more specific evidence of a
traders knowledge about the benefit the
tipper received in exchange for leaking
information in order to be convicted for
a trade so yeah it actually sort of an
open season in some respects on it so it
means that traders have to know that
this weekend that this was leaked
information and had to have benefited
from that's what they had to know that
the leaker the person inside the company
whatever company it is who gave out the
information that that person received
some kind of benefits oh I say Jane and
it has to be sort of a tangible real
benefit so so pre today on the call he
gave an example he said well you could
have a CEO of a company who decides to
give a little present to some of his
little nephews and just shares oh the
company's going to be taken over in two
weeks and those and he doesn't ask for
anything in return he just gives that as
a gift to them the the US attorney was
saying today that potentially that could
that could happen that could happen and
so people who have valuable information
could almost give it out as gifts and it
is a bit of a shocking idea when you
really think about it you know it really
changes over right yeah I mean there are
some credible of reasonable scenarios as
he just Illustrated that that could
happen so why did the Supreme Court
refuse to listen to the cases then well
it's a very good question I mean it was
sort of a 50-50 whether or not they were
going to do this and the fact is that
this was a bit of a messy case for
prosecutors to just bring to them I mean
it involved to hedge fund traders they
were four or five people removed from
the companies and the information so
they really got it through a game of
broken telephone like someone told their
friend who told their friend who told
their friend and frankly the case was a
little messy you know it wasn't the sort
of nice clean case that I think
ultimately the Supreme Court may want to
choose to weigh in on this because it's
a very important subject and needs to be
clarified so our hedge fund manager
around the country celebrating this well
I know of a couple in particular who are
and those are the two traders at the
harvest case so they basically todd
newman and anthony chiasson from
diamondback and level global their lives
have been in limbo for five years i mean
in 2010 the FBI went in and raided their
hedge funds and carted out their
computers and this has been going then
they were convicted then their
conviction was overturned and now
they've just been waiting to move on
with their lives so this for them not a
man they are finally free this is done
for them